Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David Hartz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy July 2016 was in Germany a month
of jihad Terror attacks committed by
Muslim migrants it was a hint of what
all of Europe will be like in the near
future on July 18th a teenage Muslim
Refugee hacked at passengers on a train
in verburg with an axe wounding five on
July 22nd a Muslim teenager whose
parents were migrants from Iran murdered
nine people in Munich on July 24th a
Muslim Refugee from Syria killed a woman
with a machete and wounded five other
people that same day another Muslim
Refugee from Syria blew himself up
outside a bar in ansbach wounding 15
people the events unfolded in the most
deadly of these attacks the one in
Munich in predictable fashion a young
Iranian Muslim opened fire at a shopping
mall in Munich with an eyewitness saying
that he was screaming Allahu Akbar and
initial mainstream media reports were
that the gunman was a right-wing
extremist who is lashing out on the
fifth anniversary of the ma Massacre
perpetrated by Norwegian madman Andre
braik while screaming out his hatred for
foreigners as it happened his hatred for
foreigners was not something he had
screamed out at all it was someone else
screaming his hatred for foreigners at
the Jihad murderer not the other way
around but once again the LIE had gotten
half halfway around the world before the
truth had a chance to put on its shoes
and the same old comedy The Familiar one
that plays out every week now in modern
Multicultural Europe and North America
duly played out again to an increasingly
bored and indifferent crowd Munich
police chief uberus Andre informed the
world that the young Jihadi had no known
links to Jihad Terror groups and added
the motive or explanation for this crime
is completely unclear unclear really
what is it about Akbar and the Gunning
down of innocent civilians that you
don't understand ha Andre and the answer
of course is everything uberus sandre
and Angela Merkel and Teresa may and
Manuel vs John KY and Barack Obama and
every last one of the other Western
leaders are resolutely and determinedly
ignorant about what it means when a
young Iranian Muslim screaming Allahu
Akbar opens fire in a shopping mall what
after all could it possibly mean this
young man must have come from a troubled
home right he must have grown up in
poverty and been denied access to all
sorts of economic opportunities that
were open to Native Germans of his age
right he must have been radicalized on
the Internet by shadowy forces that
somehow possess the magic power to turn
benign peaceful Muslims who are a
benefit and asset to every Western
nation into misunderstands of their own
religion who suddenly and inexplicably
discard the peaceful Islamic teachings
they have em bibed from youth in their
Western mosques in favor of a twisted
and hijacked version of their religion
that leads them to think that treason
and mass murder are not only commendable
but blessed by the almighty isn't that
the case the Munich shooter's motive is
completely unclear because we don't yet
know if he was teased in school or on
the job or if he had trouble getting a
job in the first place or if he had
psychological problems or if he was a
brooding loner who always left his
moderate Muslim friends disquieted the
only thing we do know is that he
couldn't possibly have been motivated by
religion that exhorts its adherence to
slay them wherever you find them as the
Quran tells Muslims to do in three
different passages oh no none of that is
true and one wonders if even the
European and North American political
and media Elites even believe their own
nonsense anymore the Munich mass
murderer screamed Akbar he was motivated
by Islam pure and simple by its
teachings of warfare against unbelievers
and the necessity to subjugate them his
war cry of Allahu Akbar demonstrates
that in fact that cry is revered by
jihadis for its power to strike Terror
in the hearts of the enemies of Allah as
the Quran also directs Muslims to do the
Islamic State's repeated calls for the
mass murder of civilians in Western
countries also demonstrate that uberus
Andre and Angela Merkel and Teresa may
and Manuel vs and John KY and Barack
Obama and every last one of the other
Western leaders persist in pretending
that incidents such as the mass murder
in Munich recently and the mass murders
in nce Orlando Brussels Paris San
Bernardino Chattanooga and elsewhere
also recently are all separate discret
criminal acts unrelated to one another
and all requiring extensive
investigation to determine the motives
of the perpetrators that proposition is
not only false it's a big lie Allah ysf
Geral these are not criminal acts these
are not the acts of the psychopathic or
the disenfranchised these are acts of
War battles in a larger war that has
been going on for 1400 years and is
picking up speed in our own age courtesy
of our willfully myopic and feckless
leaders unless and until Western
authorities begin to treat each of these
incidents as part of a larger War they
will continue to misdiagnose the problem
and apply the wrong Solutions and that
is the one thing they are certain to do
and so there will be many many more
Munich followed by the next flurry of
predictable denials and off
fisc what is it going to take to get
leaders who are in touch with reality
seriously is that too much to ask I'm
Robert Spencer